[Musique]
ok puce
c'est kit ouais j'ai besoin que tu le sentes c'est
froid c'est gris tu es couvert de peaux
oh et tu auditionnes avec une grande
star hollywoodienne oh vraiment
hé et action tiens frère la Bête
peut sentir ton  peur
dragon montre
toi  J'expliquais juste le Q
le Q est ah d'accord soyez honnête édenté est-ce que
j'ai l'air trop maussade hmm parce que
tout le temps j'essaie juste de me rappeler
où j'ai laissé mes clés frères
nous ne verrons pas tous l'aube mais le dragon se montre
dent ça non non pose le
catering stop notch mate
j'ai ton saumon je suis un peu confus à
propos de mon rôle vraiment en premier je suis mort
alors je ne le suis pas personne ne te connaît ma mère
est des frères nous avons quatre forts  nous nous sommes
battus dur et nous devons continuer à nous
battre jusqu'à ce que nos ennemis puissent s'adapter
[Musique]
à  ça ne vous dérangerait pas si je le suis, pouvons-nous le
faire nettoyer s'il vous plaît frais impertinent
Burke ils sont le takapa ho vous faites le pouvoir local a
pensé à moi pour lober une pagaie
Alicante ne pas assister à suto enlever les morts
sont partis
Eric Wakita destin sécurisé Zhu Zhu a dit
Sam et cachet à Sigma home safe comme
suspect habituel IVA et Betsy
picklent chacun plus de police sur monsieur
[Musique]
Je ne suis pas tsipras fue Booya -
Makaha de casa de cache de Tina préfère que je fasse
da certainement besoin d'un nouveau contrôle d'informations de version
Amanda elle  devrait décorer
monsieur quad à Tina
elle a failli et quelque chose se passe
voir votre e-mail est arrivé Asifa l'a laissée aller
voter malgré qu'ils aient fixé un nouveau dollar je
prends racine
hé ne reçois pas le croquis d'un vendeur non
tu vois le bouton sauce cynique
Tamia répéteurs dans la batterie  baby-sitter le
long de Jessie existe Obama
le Heysel moka tom facile
ouais oh ouais le Jamuna c'est un Novelli
Ahnold en ligne
[Musique]
toi